bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec mon frère tu es france votre
réaction après l'allocution est fière
foire du président de la république
alors tout d'abord bonjour alors notre
réaction par rapport à l'intervention du
président de la république hier vous
avez repris le passage important un des
passe à un des passages importants
il nous faudra rebâtir une indépendance
agricole nous à la coordination rurale
nous avons toujours alerté sur la
fragilité de notre alimentation sur la
baisse croissante et constante du nombre
d'agriculteurs
quand d'autres mettez en avant la
vocation exportatrice de la france donc
oui il nous faut en fait ce que nous
avons toujours défendu une exception
agriculturelle et se retourner vers le
marché intérieur
on a trop souvent voulu nous faire
croire qu'on pouvait produire loin de
chez soi pour avoir accès à moindre coût
une alimentation
or aujourd'hui sans politique sans
relocalisation relocalisation massive de
la production sans une politique pour
des installations en nombre dans dix
quinze ans nous ne sommes pas sûrs de
pouvoir faire face
d'un point de vue alimentaire à une
nouvelle crise alors justement
l'indépendance agricole on l'entend
depuis très longtemps dans la bouche des
agriculteurs justement lorsqu'on les
interroge c'est une revendication qui
revient très souvent on a le sentiment
qu emmanuel macron il est décidé cette
fois à changer son curseur concernant la
filière
vous le croyez sincère parce que
finalement on l'a avec cette crise
sanitaire on a vraiment l'impression que
la france n'a plus le choix
en fait c'est une rupture il a dit la
possibilité de planifier donc ça
s'inscrit ça ne s'inscrit pas dans la
continuité des politiques décidées
jusqu'à présent avec toutes ces
politiques de libre échange avec
la suppression des de toutes les
politiques de régulation de la
production que sont les quotas laitiers
les quotas betteraviers et demain
peut-être la filière viticole donc est
il sincère
certainement qu'il sait qu'il faut faire
quelque chose maintenant jusqu'à quel
niveau
serons nous accompagner pour justement
cette souveraineté alimentaire et cette
relocalisation
alors justement en ce qui concerne la
souveraineté agricole alimentaire cela
suppose quoi au niveau européen au
niveau de la politique agricole commune
ça suppose de rééquilibrer les
productions
on sait tous que nous sommes
exportateurs aux céréales et d'un autre
côté en fruits et légumes nous importe
en plus de la moitié de ce que nous
consommons est pour beaucoup de
productions nous pouvons faire le même
bilan donc
nous voyons aujourd'hui avec le
coronavirus certains pays ferment leurs
frontières pour stocker plutôt que
d'exporter
c'est le cas du vietnam par rapport au
riz c'est le cas de l'ukraine de la
russie chacun des pays aujourd'hui
favorise d'abord sa politique
alimentaire avant d'aller à l'export et
nous devons justement faire le bilan de
nos besoins et des capacités de
production que nous avons on nous assure
qu'il n'y aura pas de pénurie
alimentaire
qu'en pensez vous non bien sûr il n'y
aura pas de pénurie alimentaire
la production elle est excédentaire ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui ces mêmes que
nous risquons de devoir jeter d'aller
vers du gaspillage alors même que dans
certaines parties du monde
des personnes meurent de faim la filière
agricole elle souffre d'une pénurie de
main d'oeuvre on le disait c'est pour
cela que le ministère de l'agriculture a
appelé les français sans activité a
donné un coup de main à la filière vous
accueillez ou comment cette mesure et
que faut-il faire justement pour
soutenir encore plus les agriculteurs
alors déjà je dirais deux points avant
de démarrer le salaire en agricoles sont
des salaires au-dessus du smic et on est
aussi bien payés que dans n'importe quel
autre filière ensuite on ne tombe pas
malade en venant travailler chez les
agriculteurs contrairement à ce que j'ai
pu lire c'est un procès injuste qui est
fait à l'agriculture et c'est une des
raisons pour laquelle aujourd'hui on
manque de personnel dans nos
exploitations nos expos nos nos écoles
forment des jeunes et pour la bretagne
un seul sur quatre qui sortent des
écoles d'agriculture fini par travailler
en exploitation or un agriculteur fait
travailler sept autres personnes
en gros quand nous travaillons dans nos
fermes nous avons sept personnes à nous
dire comment travailler
donc oui aujourd'hui nous avons besoin
de personnel maintenant pourquoi il est
fait appel en général à de la main
d'oeuvre étrangère notamment dans les
fruits des filières fruits et légumes
c'est parce que c'est une main
volontaire et à partir du moment où elle
s'est déplacée elle va rester plusieurs
mois
or ici le problème et les agriculteurs
comprennent la bonne volonté de toutes
les personnes qui s'inscrivent pour
venir en renfort sur nos exploitations
et elles seront rémunérées
sauf que nous allons les former pour que
ces personnes travaillent une journée
une semaine peut-être avant la fin du
confinement ils seront partis et nous
avons une obligation de rendement si ces
travailleurs récolte 5 kg de fraises à
l'heure on sait que le coût de la main
d'oeuvre sur un kilo de fraises sera au
moins de 3 euros
et alors que quelqu'un de confirmé à une
personne qui a l'habitude récoltera deux
à trois fois plus de fraises donc il ya
cette notion de coût et et de qualité
dans le sens où nos fruits sont des et
nos légumes sont fragiles et il faut les
maintenir en état pour qu'il finisse
avec de beaux aspects pour les
consommateurs merci beaucoup vers et
véronique heures le floch
je rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
général de la coordination rurale merci
à vous